[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm late and I'm
red length and rat this week at the
round table of dim lighting you've asked
us anything and everything and we will
answer anything and everything
at least the questions that we
specifically chose from the questions
that you asked so it's not really ask us
anything
let's ask us anything and we'll answer
some things but probably shouldn't sell
it short because now it doesn't seem as
epic as it could the answers we're gonna
give or they're gonna be could go
anywhere they could go anywhere you've
asked us anything and now we can answer
anywhere
and let me say men say it man we've been
shooting some stuff today what a day we
got some mythical morning under our belt
oh gosh I went to the bathroom in the
middle of something that I guess we were
eating something we're always eaten
while we're eating you were crapping
your pants this is the kind of thing you
gotta tell her brother hey know there
was a stop down as we call it there was
like a pause in the filming and I went
to the restroom to get something out of
my teeth was a very bad understood I was
just curious
whenever you floss your teeth what
percentage of the time I'm gonna ask you
anything is it that's not how this works
I'll answer though do you do you floss
all of your teeth because you just went
in to floss one tooth crevice and then
you're like let's sense I'm here I'm
gonna hit this one and then I'm gonna
hit this one cuz that's what I did in
the bathroom there was something I felt
something in the back like in a molar
and I got that out and I was like I'm
gonna keep going and before I knew it I
was flossing every single tooth crevice
I'd say 37 percent of the time I do that
and all you guys were out there waiting
he was kind of a power play on my part I
know oh I've got to floss my teeth
no one knew you were missing so I don't
think it works but that ain't true I
would say the money in film of that the
minority of times of the time I do that
I'm not a good philosopher and of a
shamed you
you know what changed my flossing habits
what I was good at flossing because I
was going to a dentist who was telling
me that I needed a floss and then I read
an article this it's funny how just a
little study in a journalist who taina
turns it a little bit they say did you
click babies no they said yeah I was
click waited click flossing to realize
why you should never floss again
flossing not as important as once
thought click and I clicked on and I was
like alright and then my flossing
frequencies severely dropped and I don't
even know if it was real I don't I mean
it said it we were sunny probably one
study fake news man I mean all I know is
that now when i flossed my gums bleed
which is a really bad sign you know I'm
such a creature of habit but I have not
incorporated flossing into my routine
you can over floss except the day before
but the morning that I'm going to the
dentist and then for like every other
day for the two weeks after I've exited
the dentist and the hygienist is giving
me the speech when you're trying to
maintain that's the clean feeling and
then when I get something caught in my
teeth so use that 30% that means that
you have stuff caught in your teeth that
you just floss out but you don't even
use that as an occasion to floss out
your teeth you should at least do that I
do that and 80% of the time that I have
floss every between every tooth is
because I started out just trying to get
something out of one place so you need
to you need to take advantage of that
okay note taken
forget about that article so I and when
I do floss it just gives me it boosts my
esteem for at least six more hours I
feel like I'm on the tail end of a just
flossing fresh esteem boost and I'm
gonna ride it right through this air
biscuit didn't you just this is like
we're talking like now six hours and
you're still writing the floss wave six
hours six hour away from me yeah wow you
should do that more often it's like it
if it does that for you and it doesn't
hit me immediately it's like yeah I'm
flossing
yeah I'm spitting yeah there's some
blood and yeah I'm going back to my job
but then like within the hour I'm like
you know what i flossed and then within
two hours it's like it's it's really
humming
it sounds like you might be a little
prideful I mean and you know it's called
floss pride a lot of people suffer from
it well this this is your biscuit I I
feel like it's really gonna benefit from
it and I didn't want to take full credit
remember this I don't want to be
prideful I want to give floss the credit
it's due
now growing up we were taught that pride
was a buzz it was a bad thing and it is
a bad thing coming you can't cometh
before a fall but you can be proud and I
remember like we'd be playing like a
school or I'd see somebody and their
mascot was the pride of lions I guess
yeah I guess it was but it would be like
the Polka Shawnee pride or something
okay honey I'm making things up like I'd
see it in a movie I don't think we
played anybody that was called the pride
and I was like that's so arrogant yeah
that they're called the pride I bet they
floss every morning but it was because
they were lions and it never never
crossed my mind
I'm also excited bless you bless you
bless you Jake LSU Jake you have no
pride in all your endeavors from here on
out I can tell you you've lost a reason
though a smile on your face don't show
that's why I don't floss I'm riding the
floss wave right into I'm gearing up for
for this vacation and you know we talked
about it today we're taking like a mini
kid vacation yours listen okay don't
undersell your vacation kids Spring
Break my vacation is a mini vacation you
my friend are going big and going hard
oh gosh I mean it was not enough time I
am almost scared I'm scared for you I
could well I was excited and I told I
told you who was it it was you and
Darrin and Swiss TV there Steve and I
was like yeah I'm pretty excited we're
going is that where you're going it's
like we're going to the Grand Canyon
okay on an RV it's like we're renting an
RV and then their faces and your face is
like oh gosh I'm so it's like I told you
my diagnosis or something and I'm like
well you've told me how my kids want to
go on an RV nerd interact especially
Lando
I just mispronounced his name especially
the land no he wants to go the RV he and
Lando wants to go on listen let me tell
you I think that it's a great idea I
think every family should try I'm glad
you're going before me we have five days
including travels so it's very
aggressive you've got five people too I
mean it says it's one of the have you
seen these RVs that like on the side of
it it's like painted with a billboard
that says cruise improves America listen
I'm pretty sure that that's what I'm
getting it's all getting a driving
billboard it's an advertisement how can
you not how could you miss cruise
America well how much is I'm paying
because it's a big truck man
you're it is your home you're sleeping
in it right yes of course I'm not buying
it what's the point of an RV if you're
not gonna sleep in it that's the cool
part man you do know you cannot crap in
it you know that's the RV rule that's
the bus rule and the RV rule
nobody craps in it you listen where are
we gonna crap me six days do you crap in
bathrooms
you do somebody unloads in that thing
and you will be hating yourself yeah
because you know the guy who gives it to
you be like oh sure it works it never
works any time I've ever been in a bus
or an RV where somebody has dropped a
deuce uh-huh it has soiled the
experience until somebody has to come
and pump it out you got it we gotta get
somebody to come pump it out think about
you know Emer what happened on the set
of buddy system and the trailers that we
were in in your trailer yeah so the
security guard thank you
it was after hours and something was
wrong with the bathroom that he was
supposed to go in so he just picked a
random trailer and he picked my specific
trailer I think he knew he was targeting
your trailer and and just put things
into perspective here when I say trailer
don't picture like what Robert Downey
jr. is in on the set of Iron Man no we
have basically it's not quite it's
basically a series of like closets on a
trailer that you know you do have a
little sink and you've got a little
place you can lay down well I can't lay
down and then you've got a bathroom for
yourself and that's
what our trailer was ours were right
next to each other well they were both
in the same trailer they subdivided the
one trailer we had a shared wall but
different toilet I did not smell through
the wall but it was horrible it was
absolutely all right I can't I can't do
that we're gonna make eye contact with
that guy the rest of the time he was he
was guarding us because of what he did
he did he soiled he soiled my my place I
don't trust my middle child with this my
diaper I might not be able to bring him
get him diapers you should have a set of
adult diapers I'm not joking because
what's gonna happen is when you get out
now listen just stick with me for a
second when you when you get out there
in the desert and you're not familiar
with the landscape you don't necessarily
know where the bathrooms are somebody's
like dad I just got to do it there's a
toilet what's gonna happen is there's
gonna be a moment of weakness and you're
gonna be like well I mean this is a
modern this is a modern piece of
equipment there is a bathroom Rhett's
probably wrong about this I'm just gonna
let him let him crap in there what if
that if it gets to that point you say
son I have a diaper for you well if
we're out in the desert sauna have a
shovel for you just go dig a hole behind
the RV well the diaper was not really to
be used it was a tactic it was a
mind-control tactic once it once a 12
year old or 13 year old begins to think
about crapping in a diaper they become
super self-conscious and they they
pucker up and they hold it until you get
to a real bathroom not you though you're
talking about waitomo you go right in
that diaper with you oh I've never
aircraft in a diaper but I did short on
the way to Dollywood I've heard the
story but the the the way you delivered
it with such gusto in that moment it's
like wow good times
Wow put that on a t-shirt so I I'm going
to the Grand Canyon oh you know I plan
on giving you loyal listener a report
you know maybe you're right I'll let you
know if it comes down to this I'll be
thinking about you I wanted to ride a
mule down into the bottom of the Grand
Canyon with all of my with all
family another weird idea I can't like
actually it's a great idea I came home I
was like guys you know we're gonna do
Grand Canyon you know we're going on an
era via but did you know that when we
get there we are getting on a caravan of
mules and we're riding to the bottom of
the Grand Canyon one of the seven
wonders of the world is it not it should
be if it's not it's one of the natural
wonders of the American world yeah and
immediately it was just like people it
was like a bailing out of a sinking ship
I mean I mean like Christie was like
gave me a are you nuts
yeah like I'm afraid of I'm afraid of
heights
yeah you you want to put me on top of a
animal on the teetering on the edge of
switchbacks which it is and then
Lincoln's like I'm afraid of horses
oh that's a bigger problem I'm like well
it's a mule it's not a horse right
it's sterile it's so sure-footed and
then Lando is too young so I mean we
were leaving him behind in the thicket
anyway somehow with Jade Jade's coming
to in the RV but you're serious I'm
serious
Wow I talked to me how are you gonna
mule this is my idea there's no way I
mean I think take well I think they
abandoned me something like Lily please
come with me to ride on the mules and
she's like I don't know I don't want to
dad go by yourself I'm like yeah you'll
love it you'll you'll absolutely love it
it'll just be me and you and the mules I
think it's a great idea the reason I
said it's a weird idea is because I knew
that your family would would not be into
it but if you want to take a mule with
me one day and how do you ride a mule
heck yeah I do that yeah you better
believe I'm not hiking up from the
bottom of the Grand Canyon with my
family you know it's the only way to see
and I really want to ride a horse too
yeah I I don't necessarily know if your
first horse back riding experience
should be a on a mule and be at the
Grand Canyon because that's kind of a
different experience yeah it's a
different thing you know interesting
like riding the monorail at Disney World
versus getting on the you know a SpaceX
rocket it's a different thing I will be
incidentally at this
time that you're in your aura via I will
be on horseback what yeah I have it
that's one of the days I have plan on my
medication which is less ambitious I'm
just going to Palm Springs you get you
get you get a ride on a horse there's a
whole Act there's an excursion I'm going
to this is your family coming with you
all four of us get our own horse it's
hurts man and you know what for just a
little bit extra they said for a little
bit extra per person it'll be just us
with no strangers no randos no rakau boy
taking you around
no no we've got we've got a qualified
person but no other tourists right just
the McLaughlin's and someone who knows
what they're doing we're gonna do what
they call a jeep tour hmm like a sunset
tour and that's gonna be just us cuz I
don't like to go on tours with other
people they slow you down they get
injured and their liability and also you
never know what you're gonna get you're
just taking a random sample of people I
mean if you just throw a dart at the
human population the chances that you
hit somebody you want to hang out with
pretty slim I mean especially when
you're a jerk like me
remember the prideful thing you said
earlier yeah yeah so we'll give you
updates on that but we got to get into
some questions from you guys yes we do
but first we want to let you know that
you can have the shirts that we're
wearing not the exact shirts that we're
wearing but you can have shirts that are
exactly like the shirts we're wearing if
you go to mythical dollar store you can
get this amazing mythical sweatshirt you
can't tell by looking at this right now
but like tell me about the material of
this thing because I'm fascinated with
the material of your shirt it's a long
sleeve sweatshirt cut but the material
is astonishingly breathable and thin
it's almost like a t-shirt meets a
sweatshirt it's like a t-shirt was a
horse and the sweatshirt was a donkey
and then they made it and they made a
sterile shirt right that's a mule and
it's incidentally the same color and
a mule some mules some mules you wear
this mythical long sleeve sweatshirt
thingy you you you have no risk of
creating more shirts that shirt will
that mate is capable of reproducing
other shirts tell me about your shirt
what my shirt is there's nothing
exciting about the material it's just a
black t-shirt but there's something very
exciting about what it says and that is
not a sponsor well don't don't cover it
up with your microphone
not a sponsor trademark mythical logo
yeah can you say that at times whenever
we talk about a product 98% of the time
we say not a sponsor because 98% of the
time it's not a sponsor when we talk
about the product now you too can have
no sponsors or you could wear this shirt
and take a stance as not being a sponsor
true and all spots or anything beautiful
shirt has two meanings is open to
interpretation yeah thank you for
supporting entertainment go to mythical
dot store and stock up all right here we
go okay right off the bat here's an
interesting question from Beth and
McGraw Smith dang girl choose how many
names you gotta go out on I don't know
that's quite a few who is the most
surprising contact in your phone Beth we
liked your question so nothing
immediately came to mind I literally
pulled out my phone and I started
scrolling and I found someone that
surprised me that I think will surprise
you did you wrote something down did you
scroll your fun yeah
the first name that came up that was
surprising to you was Bill Leslie bill
Leslie anchor news anchor at WRAL yeah
absolutely
WRA on morning news May and lunchtime to
I think in Raleigh North Carolina he's a
ginger and he is like the he's the man
there at the local news situation in the
Triangle he's also a
artist yeah he's a bluegrass man I think
he's a bluegrass man and we met him in
full redneck
we get we were guests on the on WRAL and
we met him because he invited us to come
on the news program like then like the
noon news in order to sing I think it
was the barbecue starving zone we
basically went on as rabbit lightning
for all intents and purposes for Revit
lighting like exist so it was just like
two rednecks like I wore a tank top and
cutoff jean shorts and each any he met
us and took us around the new studio the
North Carolina news is like some of the
most high-quality award-winning news
outfits in the country I'm not just
bragging it's kind of a weird phenomenon
that North Carolina has really good high
production quality news and weather like
industry standard that's the fact and
when you because when you go other
places you'd be like this news sucks and
he took us around and introduced us to
everyone like people in cubicles and
like production people we were in
character the Hulk and we never we did I
don't know what because we were in our
costumes we just we never broke
character and we did he never
acknowledged it because he's because
he's cool woman he is a professional
he's so cool uh you know you're gonna
think I'm name-dropping
I got post Malone in my phone and that
rhymes post Malone in my phone because
as post me ask him for his number or we
follow each other on Twitter and he sent
me his phone number that's kind of it
and let's call him he's he Austin is his
name he's a genuine dude now we already
knew this because Mike and Alex knew him
yeah but he's just a genuinely good guy
good-hearted guy and kind of a
legitimate he's a I would call him a
sweetheart God would go as far as to say
he's a sweetheart like you say he's good
versus bad and you know I don't like
calling people good or bad but he's very
sweet I said good I think he's bad I'm
not it seems now I'm implying
he's back well he might be a little bit
of a bad boy but it's like a bad boy
good way but he's a sweetheart he's a
sweetheart
yeah bad boy good taste in comedy yeah
and you want me to continue to name-drop
I can see that you've got you've got it
more written I only have one
Redfoo I have red food made for you and
mr. Tony Hale good friend Tony Hale
those are as my name drops I've dropped
all the names that I can possibly drop
in my phone well I'm about to drop a big
name on you I found in my address book
mr. Fred van or do you don't look at my
notes you remember him
you mean the Snuggie guy yes
the guy who put the commercial producer
of the Snuggie commercials as well as a
lot of famous infomercials we I can't
remember how this happened but we were
well including like OxiClean he shot the
last commercials with billy mays mm-hmm
like days before he died yep and this
yes Snuggie and he's still doing it like
blue moon studios or something
but we had a conversation with him I
think it was because we made the ShamWow
song that's what it was made the ShamWow
song but we made just to you know we
took the ShamWow song and we we took the
ShamWow commercial and we we took the
words verbatim that Vince said and we
wrote it into a song you can search it
on YouTube it's not as great as we
thought it was at the time probably now
doesn't hold up that well but we sang we
musica fied it yeah and and then we got
an email and ultimately a conference
call with the producer of the Snuggie
commercials and they were making fred
was making a new Snuggie commercial and
he wanted us to make a song make a song
for it but that would be that would be
part of the actual commercial that went
out I like on cable that everyone would
see and he told us a lot of cool stuff
that like there was a warehouse in like
New Jersey where they may
all these commercials so likely was
almost like a right a place like you
know Willy Wonka's factory where you
could go and you would see all the
commercials being made for all the crazy
infomercial products and yeah so that's
we're so excited about you know like
people in lounging and Snuggies and then
we were thinking about what song were
gonna write and then like a week later
he calls and he's like guys turns out
that Weezer has decided to do a music
video about they're gonna be wearing
Snuggies and they're in actually
paradeen the Snuggie infomercial as
their new music music and it's actually
it was a it was a partnership an
official partnership with Snuggie and
he's like you know because we've got
that going on it doesn't really make
sense to have you guys who are not
Weezer nope and that's actually the
second worn by Weezer we got we got we
tweezer beef we got beef with Weezer
beef number one with Weezer is when we
won the key of awesome
may they rest in peace music video
contest way back in the day they're not
dead they just aren't making music
videos anymore Key of Awesome and the
award was to be able to make a music
video of Weezer now get we got to appear
go to the set and appear in a music
video bio and then we heard but and then
we turned it into we said we actually we
want we don't wanna just make a cameo we
want to make you a music video and we
want to direct a Weezer music video not
without retort we pitched two ideas I
remember one of them one of the ideas
was we were gonna take large helium
balloons like weather balloon style the
kind of balloons that people tied to
lawn chairs and then float themselves up
and we were going to float the entire
band in the air tethered to the ground
but floating in the air and then we were
going to do the same for Sarah and they
were gonna do the whole music video
floating in the air we thought was a
great idea we talked we were we were on
the phone with Weezer's manager like
pitching all this stuff yeah and we also
pitched an idea where Weezer would be in
different rooms performing the song and
we would shoot it we would shoot the
song we would shoot the performance on a
set like and it would be like kitschy
kind of like this isn't a murder
see room set but like Weezer's playing
all the different the doctors and the
person getting operated on and then it
would be a different set and a different
set and then we would change things on
these sets and then get them to perform
the song identically again and then we
would run it a split screen beside each
other and you would spot the differences
in the two Weezer musical performances
and they loved the idea and or the
manager did and we pitch it to him and
then they got cold feet and they they
backed out on the whole thing and then
we said well we're we're gonna take that
idea and then we made our video us when
a sponsor the right sponsor came along
we pitched it and then they were able to
fund yeah that was our spot the
differences in music video now so I mean
you know big fans of Weezer
may be back and all we always have been
but got we got a little Weezer beef
because we had two really good ideas
they didn't like and then they took our
Snuggie song that we could have made and
they came in and they sing with Weezer
black
yeah let's come on and let's make it up
and some let's start a Weezer beef let's
start like a Weezer Twitter beef well I
think who benefits more from that at
this point oh hey we had beef you just
really really know you said it you
really just stepped in it so we didn't
get to do the Snuggie freakin Snuggie
commercial but that is a good friend
Nora I still have your number man I'll
call I call me that's not how it works
is it I have your number call me I'll
know it's you when you call Jennifer
PTIN asks if you could change one thing
about yourselves what would it be
mmm-hmm cuts right to the heart doesn't
it Jennifer I would I would be able to
release all of my pent-up frustration
that I've been channeling towards Weezer
all these years no okay let's really
think this out now let you go first
what would you change about yourself mr.
McLaughlin well you know there are
there's a series of superficial things
that immediately come to mind like I
would give myself an actual chin you
know what I'm saying so I could
occasionally shave my beard and not be
berest you know like being locked into
the beard here but I think that the
actual deeper answer is to not care
about any I would change I would lose
the desire to want to change anything
about myself whatever I would want to
get to a place of emotional maturity
where I no longer cared about the things
that I wanted to change obviously there
are certain things that like character
things like I wish I had more patience
or I wish I was more selfless I was I
wish that I that I that I wasn't you
know I'm selfish everybody's selfish I
kind of feel like I'm probably on the
you know if you divided everybody in the
world into who's more selfish I would
think I would be on the upper end of the
spectrum of selfish people okay
I'd want to change those things but I
think most of all just thinking about
the just the fact that there's these
things that come to mind and and a lot
of it has to do with wanting to change
the way that you're perceived by people
I think I would want to not have that
like to actually be completely content
so you with with Who I am
that is the serious deep you want an
answer you want to desire to not change
anything about yourself that's not what
I said
so I would want to lose you the desire
to change the superficial things about
myself okay in other words no longer
care what anybody thinks hmm
that's a beautiful answer right oh thank
you you want to be five gave you the
answer so you'd like me more again
that's one of my problems this is tough
I don't know for me I think about I did
I just you know my I just find myself a
levels of anxiety that I just don't
think are justified so I I would like to
and I am thinking more about this and
trying to tackle it but so I guess I
mean that's what I'm working on changing
about myself that's one of the things is
coming to grips with what's behind this
like
illogical anxiety that that just kind of
Wells up you know a fear of the bottom
falling out of my life in one way or
another
you know I wish I didn't have that I am
working on that and you know I think I'm
hesitant to say I would but even that
there's something as long as you're
engaged I feel like if as I'm engaged in
the process of like getting to the
bottom of that it's a rewarding
experience you know it's I mean we're
we're tremendously blessed that there's
not something that comes to our minds
that's like I've got this nagging
problem or issue that it's like oh I
just like to remove this thing you know
like a like a like something physical
you know so I want to acknowledge that
but I could be more thankful to yeah
it's difficult to change one thing it's
difficult to pick one thing that's why I
kind of tried to pick something that
would like take care of a lot of things
I mean I cuz I think about you know I
love my kids and I think about the
things that I hope changes in them okay
you know they've got symptoms of McCain
example like selfishness or something
that you talked about that most
everybody I think deals with if they're
honest with themselves and you know
developing the ability to put other
people's needs before your own could I
would I snap my fingers and take that
and for my kids to just be there it's
like well I mean there's something you
know the cliche of it's about the it's
about the journey not the destination I
yeah maybe it's because I know this
isn't possible to just snap your fingers
and change something that's just a
rationalization but I do think there's a
beauty and the fact that you can't do
that that you kind of got a live you got
to live through things and hopefully
you're you're making positive changes
so ultimately I'm a verbal processor so
now I've landed in my answer oh good I
wish I was a little more tenacious in
tackling the things that I wanted to
improve about myself about my the way
that I think the way that a my heart
those type of things like the deepest
things that I want to improve on I'm
just I I too easily just escape to like
I'm just gonna take a nap well you know
the interesting thing I would like to
change that I would like to be more
tenacious set what's the word wrestling
you want to be a more tenacious wrestler
yeah like a self wrestler wrestling with
yourself yeah I feel like I can make
more progress if it wasn't like I
finally get around to thinking about a
levels of introspection and and mmm I
don't like to use the word
self-improvement but I just did that you
know you be see what I'm saying yeah
well you know which I was a little more
dedicated to becoming a better person at
a faster rate well you know I think one
of the things that's kind of interesting
about this that I think applies to both
of us personally is that I think given
the way that our wives kind of interact
with self-improvement yeah and given the
way that the friends that have become
our are better friends in the past
couple of years
mm-hmm are very in tune with
self-improvement
and I don't it may self-improvement may
be the wrong word and it may conjure up
things in your mind that turn you off
but people who are really concerned
about continuing to to not be stagnant
in the way that they think and the way
they approach things and continuing to
change for the better and it's like I
kind of feel like that's that's been a
huge benefit to both of us in the past
couple years because I think that
there's this part I think that you tend
to naturally think that like okay I just
turned 40 I'm kind of who I'm going to
be and I think one of the things that
I've realized in that past like two
years is that I really hope that I'm not
who I'm gonna be because I don't because
I I want to continue to change
and I actually have in light of the kind
of you know the quality of the people
that have become good friends now I
would say grow not not just change but
like change is just yeah grow up
personal growth it's a little limiting
of the term I like even in the past six
months there have been and I'm not gonna
like share very specific things because
I'm still like processing so many of
these things but there's not a sponsor
attached to it right and when I get a
sponsor I will talk about this freely
but there are very specific things that
I've learned about myself just in the
past six months that I was like man I
could have gone the rest of my life not
knowing that about myself and now that I
do know that about myself a certain kind
of work is beginning that I think
there's a personal growth that I did not
know was possible that I had no way of
anticipating and that's I've been
thinking about that lately because I do
feel like it is a it's kind of been a
revelation it's kind of like man
actually I got so much more work to do
on myself than I ever even realized
because I kind of just thought I was
pretty cool I kind of just thought
everything was pretty pretty good and
everything is pretty good in one sense
it's like I don't have a lot to complain
about being incredibly blessed in a lot
of different ways hashtag blessed which
I never used on my Twitter account which
is at Rhett MC haven't haven't plugged
myself in a while so I figured I would
do that even real I got it we're making
such a I got it I've got it you know I
got a deflect because I was getting too
real and I got to make a
self-deprecating self-promoting joke all
at the same time sorry
that's this is the kind of work that I
need to do but anyway I am I'm just I
I'm actually more excited about my 40s I
told Jesse this the other day I was like
I I'm super excited about my 40s and
it's like so many different ways like
personally professionally making you cry
I mean I don't know if I can you know
I'm not I'm not I would love to make you
cry right now can I make you cry well if
I rub my eyes hard enough they'll
probably start I am super excited about
my 40s in a way that I think that I
could have just as easily gotten to my
40s and and I do we I have questions all
the time
is our best work behind us like we you
know there's so many you're tempted to
think is the bottom gonna drop out of
whatever that is that we're doing but I
actually feel from a personal standpoint
and even from a professional standpoint
I'm more excited about the future than I
have been in a while Wow Jennifer you
really open a can uh honesty yeah you
did you never know what's gonna happen
on an air biscuit
I I wish you weren't so vague okay we
got to get a sponsor yeah next question
Kathryn able ask what songs are on your
guilty pleasures playlist I like this
question a very good question
you know that I I really enjoy hip hop
this morning I was making my smoothie to
some j.cole that's good but I'm not
guilty about that yeah that's them to be
proud of
um one of my favorite who'll one of my
favorite band save Oh North Carolina's
Lord Huron has a new single came out
which tells me I have it I keep
forgetting to search but I assume that
means an album is coming out
you never know without guys I love it i
I they may be my favorite band but
that's not a guilty pleasure no I'm not
I don't feel guilty about that but um
guilty pleasure is like Dixie Chicks
which I still listen to that here's the
chicks album boy good gracious that is
that is that okay so my guilty pleasure
is I don't know why I started thinking
about this guy in his songs but for the
past two weeks I've been obsessed I just
can't I just it's made me so happy and a
little guilty that how much I love Steve
Winwood okay give me give me a Steve
Winwood song so we revolted for divine
there smiley take me in now does he play
you know that song yeah definitely but
do they play a lot of woodwinds they
know he doesn't because you know I'm
when you know I'm getting that it seems
like Winwood wood it just feels like
it's an opportunity for a lot of
woodwinds to be playing there's other
songs like that's the main one that I
keep going back to and I swear that
James Taylor is singing backup James
Taylor found his way into so many albums
in the 70s and 80s you'll be listening
to a George Jones song and all of a
sudden that's James Taylor Darden Tanaka
bartenders blues and then you got back
in the high life again and then roll
with it baby
I'm singing them all in the same key
they're not and then um isn't mandolin
rain mandolin rain is it mandolin rain
isn't that Steve Winwood no listen to
the mandolin rain no that's Bruce
Hornsby all right that's my guilty
guilty pleasure Bruce Hornsby
does he play horns you guys Steve
Winwood play a woodwind you only listen
got Bruce horns we have to have
instruments in their last names
well that's mine so a Dixie Chicks I
can't member last time I listened to but
I'm talking about that you know the
Dixie Chicks album before they like said
the wrong thing about Bush and everybody
started hating them I'm talking about
that album but okay
I'm not sure you can do that it's a
little mandoline Ram so what I found
when I started going into my phone
trying to look at my playlists and my
recently added he's like do I have yep
okay keep that short there's legal
repercussions okay all right I think
yeah I think you've affected get to the
right part you've officially gone over
the number of seconds that we can
legally play but you know what yeah
that's it I think we all know the new
mean doesn't care the new you will care
when we have to take this podcast down I
feel so guilty see you're trying to make
me guilty now what I found and this is
gonna make you happy
I've made so many people happy with this
I don't even remember how oh I remember
how I found it what how I found Arielle
Camacho oh that's not a guilty pleasure
that's a hidden Jim don't tell him oh no
I'm going to tell him they already know
maybe so I was driving along I just had
to talk about this because as I was
looking for my guilty pleasure I looked
at my recently added and I saw from last
year how I added this album yes I was
flipping through the FM radio channels
of Los Angeles which is not something I
do often because I'm usually listen to a
podcast or you know my own songs not
like rhettandlink songs you know what I
mean like my my iTunes and about 30 to
40% of the stations that are on FM radio
in Los Angeles it seems like our you
know Spanish music and this song starts
playing tame at East and it was this
incredible music that sounded like the
you know I don't even know then
necessarily the right name for this a
little bit of like mariachi ish sound
who is it Arielle Camacho and it is
absolutely amazing because there's not a
bass guitar there's a dude playing a
freaking tuba and he's playing the tuba
in almost it sounds like he has
literally been gifted his tuba playing
ability by like an alien
force okay okay now that proper Berta
and then sometimes ago butter and this
is the bass tuba and the tuba is the
bass and so one night we're hanging
we're hanging out with one of our
friends and I had listened to this and
thought this is some of the best music
I've ever listened to I absolutely loved
it and I got the album and I just
started listening to it blew my mind I
thought I had just found this little
thing that would be this little treasure
that I could share with people from time
to time and then I'm hanging out at my
house with a friend and I bring it up
and then we were just like I wonder like
if there are music videos for this like
what are the music videos and we look at
Arielle Camacho and that's when we
realize the music videos have like
hundreds of millions of views it's
absolutely huge is a phenomenon you've
discovered nothing in Mexican snow it is
a phenomenon in Mexico especially but
also in America and we I just didn't
know about it and it turns out that like
it was the original dude who was the
lead singer was killed and then they
replaced him with a new dude yeah and
the ban is still intact the tuba tuba
players still the same guys we've got to
get him on the show but it's some of the
best music you'll ever hear Arielle
Camacho and I don't know it was REO
Camacho the first guy who died and they
just so call it that I don't know it's
so too before word it'll just it'll just
rock your thought you needed to before
word music somewhere like Michael
McDonald but get the idea what do you
want to go now let's just keep going
Katie bowling you know love a mess
pretty large following over the years I
was wondering how you honestly feel
about fans coming up to you in public
what do you draw the line so as as to
when it's okay for someone to approach
you or when it's in a pro
you know it's I'm very grateful that
we're successful enough that every time
we go out if we go out together
somewhere in public well somebody's
gonna recognize I I kind of just mosey
around until it until it happens because
I need that validation yeah you need it
for your self-esteem but so once that
happens I can be like check now I can
now I can go home and sit on my butt
yeah
and feel good about myself maybe I'll
need to floss it's like one of the other
I'm either gonna floss or get recognized
do you know I don't ride that way I
don't know which is both a six-hour wave
but my answer is there's a time when
it's inappropriate and it's when you're
I think maybe I've told the story it's
when you're in Amsterdam with your
family in your business partner and his
family that's me and you've been riding
bicycles around the city and you've
nearly gotten hit by a car another car a
train and many angry pedestrians and
it's it's bringing your wife to tears
like literally she's crying and because
it's just it was an overwhelmingly
traumatic experience watching our
children almost get hit by train and
meanwhile my wife is also crying and mad
at me and not speaking to me and so
we're out in public we separated to make
it easier but it was I mean like I was
talking to her and it was like you can I
mean you've seen couples in like heated
situations in public and if you
recognize one of them as an Internet a
nerd that's not a good time to come up
to him and ask for a photo yeah what'd
you do I was like oh my wife can take
the photo know which one maybe no I did
not say that but um you say this is not
a good time or did you know I took the
photo oh you did but didn't it would
nobody won I'm sure it wasn't a great
photo and you know who you are if you've
got it
yeah and I think I told this story
before about the time I was in the
airport and I was this is when we had
missed our flight we were about to miss
our flight
I don't remember I wasn't there I wasn't
no and I was with my family and I was
panicking and first of all you may
consider yourself the
more anxious one and you are in general
but when it comes to airport travel well
that's cuz yours you also have strategic
thinking which sometimes leads to
anxiety I am incredibly anxious and my
wife and my kids these log they have
running jokes about me and the way that
I you know we get to the air it really
worked out 14 hours before the flight
you get frantic yeah and I don't and if
I'm a fan and from 50 yards away I can
tell that's frantic Rhett I did it
that's not the Rhett that I know is in
the middle of like a heated exchange
about how we had to get going or
whatever and somebody came up one in a
picture and I'm sure that I was not I
was not nice I don't I think I might
have said this is not a good time I
can't remember I told the story and when
it was fresher when I had closer access
to the memory and I think I told it you
know accurately but the point is you I
mean there's a there's a time and place
and that's not it last night we were
together this is we're in Hollywood you
know how we just go and hang out
Hollywood looking for looking to be
recognized walk around Hollywood because
did you notice what happened I think we
didn't talk about it we were coming off
that escalator at Hollywood Highland and
somebody well they the guy like kind of
grabbed my arm and turned me around and
then was like rhett and Link I'm a big
fan I can I get a photo and then he he
did himself and he like he did some sign
with his hand and he was like trying to
be really but no he also asked the same
question twice I think he was he may
have been under the under something yep
the other thing that I would ask that
people not do - I don't know I reckon
grabbed you yeah when he grabs you got
it you got to go into a martial arts
what he didn't he hit he took the back
of his hand
and at just above my elbow and he turned
me towards him you can't let that kind
of thing have somebody begins to turn
you you go into him and you just you
shove there neighs no nasal cavity right
into their brain you you got it you got
you got it just turn around and just
like a like a movie it's somebody
touches you you got to kill him yeah
the dude just wanted to suck you sorry
maybe I'm overreacting I think my
personal bass is incredibly important to
me don't okay don't kill anybody because
they touch you I'm sorry it was a poor
Bulova we're both there I know what you
don't want to touch yeah take it all
back
all right we can move on to another
question I feel good about now like in a
you know and kind of a roundabout way
acknowledging how popular we are let's
move on oh yeah
Pete metalic asks have any of your
gastrointestinal adventures landed you
in front of a doctor what is the worst
thing you have experienced as a result
of consuming something on GMM looking
down at our round table under the dim
lighting and we had all the guests from
like the first two Z's of ear biscuit to
sign it when we had guests I see Smosh
right there which reminds me I mean it
goes without saying all the hot peppers
I've eaten has been very difficult we
never went to the doctor for we've never
been to the doctor for anything related
specifically to the show unless sitting
so long gave me hemorrhoids and then I
can maybe I should have filed workers
comp mmm for that visit but we had we do
over donto and one of the things was you
they decided not to drink a liter of
vinegar I think is how it went so we had
it was a leader but it was we had to
drink a pint not it was a lot it I think
they call it a leader but like a pint of
like red vinegar at red apple cider
vinegar and we chugged it and it I felt
horrible at first then we kept playing
the game and then you actually I get a
almost vomitus yeah feeling just
thinking about it like it the way that I
felt after drinking that like oh gosh it
makes me want to vomit right now
thinking about it oh gosh and then we
kept playing the game and I was like man
I do not feel good I started sweating
and I said keep the cameras rolling
because if I vomit I I want you to film
it it's all over the clicks and then I
sat there and then we were
done and like we like anthony and Ian
this is way back when they were together
you know way back in the day where the
good ol days wash with Smosh when Smosh
was smosh smosh is it's just something
it's something now it's just something
different that's right
it's bigger we hugged him goodbye gave
him the friendlies and then then I was
like keep filming me because I'm
evolving and then like 20 minutes later
I was just sitting there alone in the
studio with a camera on me and then I
gave up and the moment I stood up after
sitting there for that long I was like
oh my gosh you had gone I was like you
gone somewhere else in the studio I was
like I went to the bathroom and I threw
up all that vinegar of course I
immediately felt better and I was so
grateful but I went home because I'm not
one to vomit in general I've talked
about it before the the McLoughlin
streak we had like 30 to 40 years
between me and my brother and my dad if
not vomiting I have broken that a couple
of times but there's just a there is a
great hesitancy to vomit even when your
body is telling you to do it there's we
have all kinds of techniques of heavy
breathing and you know shifting the body
that keeps it from coming up it's kind
of like a esophagus chastity belt yeah
exactly and I went home that night it
was a it was a Friday night because
because I remember Saturday waking up
and well I
that night I was I went out we were
meeting some friends for dinner and at
this like burger place they're like
ordering these huge burgers and I'm like
I can't I can't eat anything I was just
so gastrointestinal traumatized so I sat
there and watched him eat these huge
burgers and I'm getting text
I started getting texts from Rhett
mmm-hmm
he's like dude I'm I'm not doing good
and I was actually not only was I was I
not doing well I was doing what I often
do which is I was going on the internet
and asking the internet questions about
the way I was feeling given what you had
done and what I learned is that there
are documented cases of people dying
from vinegar overdoses then I was like I
don't know how much you can take you can
take but I don't
a whole lot and like people were like
this is definitely not a good thing now
but you weren't were you typing your
personal case into the to a forum no I
never do that I look at other people's
answers because typing your case into a
forum when you've got like a very
temporary problem by the time somebody
answers it's over so it was why help
anybody else but what I learned is that
it's not a selfish man you give it's not
a gift it's not a good thing to drink a
large amount of vinegar a lot of people
will drink apple cider vinegar
therapeutically or gargle with or
whatever and I think that drinking you
know small amounts is like a super
healthy thing yeah but drinking the
amount that we did was is not good for
you
and so I was in this had this dull ache
to my stomach that I couldn't get rid of
and then I wake up in the morning on
Saturday and it's still there yeah I had
trouble sleeping it was like Saturday
night by the time it went away you never
threw up no I was scared too I can't
make myself throw up like sometimes to
people you can did you pee in occur I'm
sure isn't that a saying and one layer
hissing the vinegar wait us now it might
be but I mean yeah I think technically I
was but it wasn't straight vinegar and I
didn't burn I did not taste it to
confirm if it was still vinegar because
I hated vinegar so much at the time I
got it out of my system eventually and
we I think the as the show has gotten
older and we've got more people involved
in the show we have their more rigorous
or their much right now it's as rigorous
they're saying those piss and vinegar a
phrase used to express an attitude of
somebody that is full of integer energy
vigor perhaps rowdiness or excitedness
piss and vinegar well a patient vinegar
that is not what you were you were full
of both of those things but it did not
make you that description but things
like almost overdosing on vinegar are
almost blowing ourselves up by mixing
two substances that should not be mixed
those things don't happen anymore
because we have that many more people
who like check and make sure that we're
gonna be okay so the whole saved GMM
hashtag that came up
a couple years ago when people are like
really you're gonna die because they're
pushing themselves so far it's not gonna
happen now I of course I talked about
the peanut butter thing and then that
came out and you guys who listened to my
story here then there was a lot of
concern in the after in the comment
section of that but I don't know I
didn't feel I didn't feel great about
making you you got so worried about it
what about this question from Macy who
asks how late is too late to wish
someone a happy birthday that day I mean
the next day is not their birthday the
next day you say happy belated birthday
okay right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
what is your opinion about that because
I have not in not-too-distant past with
two different friends because again
we've established I'm pretty selfish I'm
not a very good friend I'm not a very
good friend long distance like via text
so if you're on the other side of the
country or whatever and so I find out
it's somebody's birthday and I'm gonna
text him and then I don't and then the
next day I'm like I said I got him and
so I don't know how many days I've gone
but what what is I always say happy late
birthday but what is too late when is it
too late to still say happy late cuz
we're definitely saying happy late
birthday or happy belated however you
want to phrase it how long can that last
I mean I don't know if 48 hours oh
really I was thinking a week a week oh
you could just add you could add
qualifiers to it happy super belated
birthday a week ago I think you got to
start getting into apology letter
territory at this point hey man sorry
about this but I wanted to wish you a
happy super belated birthday feel bad
even talking to you now that I've waited
so long but I really hope you had a
great birthday and you know what happy
really super super early birthday for
next year just in case I forget again
that's a good text you could just take
that and cut cut and paste I'll take
credit for it I think because I'm I I
hope I'm not lying to myself when I say
this I think
because I'm so prone to forget birth
dates that I don't it doesn't hurt my
feelings when people don't call me on my
birthday
like I like loved ones like like if my
if my dad were to call me the day after
bi I understand it's you know there's a
three-hour time difference that it
surprisingly it does make a huge
difference in wishing somebody happy
birthday when there's a three-hour time
difference if you're like working all
day and you can't just stop what you do
we are such a compartmentalize thinker
we all those things because all our
people are on these codes my dad didn't
do that but even somebody as close as my
dad I I don't think I would care but
there might be other psychology involved
in that it's like I hate making people
feel like they they need to apologize
well I I'm you know me like I'm so prone
to it I am yes so I might be pretty
pretty negligent when it comes to a lot
of things but the one thing I will never
you'll never get from me is you will
never feel judged because you didn't get
something for me or you didn't tell me
happy birthday or you didn't include me
or you didn't invite me like you know
and again it's probably because I'm a
people pleaser and so I don't want
people to be upset with me or thinking
I'm upset with them but so at least I
got that because I think the worst
combination would be if you were like
really bad at keeping up with things
like that and being a good friend but
you were also hypersensitive to when
people didn't give it to you don't dish
it out if you can't take it yeah I just
don't take it I don't dish it out Lexie
Woodruff asks what do animals think cars
are we're getting we're getting
philosophical here how do animals view
technology this is interesting because I
was bringing Jaden MX ago into work and
she sits in the passenger seat I do not
let her sit in my lap though she wants
to when I'm driving do you put the seat
belt on hard it no and a lot of people
would hate you for that
well think you got a strap
again well if you strap a kid in won't
you strap a dog I you know what I agree
with that and I should get one
you're seriously gonna get one what what
if I was in an accident something
happened to her it would be horrible
like I would be I could that would be
horrible alright so I could I couldn't
bear it but then but in order to be
ready for that you have to be the guy
that straps his dog into the seats
nobody has to see it what what I what
I'm I'll see you what I am really
against is the people who let their dog
sit on their left arm that's on the
steering wheel and then drape over on
the window like that's not that's not
safe yeah okay for anybody it's not
quite texting while driving but it is
especially the dogs like a dog in your
lap while you're I mean I had that's my
opinion I could be wrong
I had Barbara come from the back go
under the front seat and come out in the
floorboard one time like when she was
small well Jay did that last weekend
when we were parked at the grocery store
parking lot
talk about a panicky situation boy how
she down there with the pedals man was
she gonna do she doesn't know how which
pedal does what she's gonna floor it
yeah shut the emergency brake off she
could pop the hood all kinds of things
gonna happen down there so Jade was in
the other seat curled up like a donut
I'm sleeping and I and I let go I looked
over at her and I was like that dog has
no clue where we're going included that
dog didn't have a clue yeah that clue
doesn't have a dog you know it's like
man I I don't know what she thinks of
the vehicle I mean she she knows that
it's a transport device that I leave in
that thing and so if I let her out the
front door when I leave and I get in the
transport device she tries to get in
with me so she can come with me so she
knows it's a it's it's where I'm it's
what I leave in mmm-hmm
but I don't think her view of it as the
technology goes much beyond that
I don't you know she likes to look out
the window sometimes she knows it's
moving but it's like wow yeah I just
don't think she puts much thought into
it does she recognize when you get close
to your house on the way back like when
do you think
that Jade nose yeah you're getting home
because I've got some theories about one
barber nose uh when I turn on the final
Street but here's my point I was looking
down at her and I was like she has no
clue where we're going it could be it
could be anywhere and she's just living
in the moment you know it's one of the
things that I love about having a dog
and now that this whole world of being a
dog person has opened up to me finally
and I'm wrapped around her paw I just
try to find different ways to for for
psychologically it improved my life and
and the way that I discovered right then
was you know what every time I hang out
with Jade I'm gonna appreciate how she's
able to live in the moment she doesn't
know where she's going in her life or in
this car and she's just you know what
I'm here for it I'm here for it hmm I'm
sure so I try to live like a dog a dirty
dog the only issue with that is that
she's not processing any of that no
she's not in the way that you would if
all of a sudden you weren't happening
her body if all of a sudden your brain
was inside her body you wouldn't be able
to embody it in the way that she does
that would be frustrating because in
order to get to the place where you're
just always living in the moment you got
to be as dumb as a dog
exactly yeah I guess I don't want to be
that dumb you think when does Bart
barber knows when she's getting home
pretty closer I think she knows when I'm
on the road that goes that goes up the
hill to my house like so the elevation
changes she jumped the she big issue I
think she my theory is she smells home
not home she doesn't smell my home but
she smells our neighborhood Jesse got
that Jesse got that a book about all the
stuff that dogs can do hmm
and it's like I don't know what it's
called something about your amazing dog
or sister
it's probably not called that it's got a
better title net cuz it was like a New
York Times bestseller but it goes
through all these amazing examples of
how well a dog's nose work did you know
that dogs that track individuals mm-hmm
who were running from them and have been
trained to do this talking like an
escaped convict type City yeah like hair
like Harrison Ford and fugitive which
what was his name Richard what was the
guy's name in that fugitive does it
matter
doesn't matter at all but it's just one
of those things that I want to know now
that I've thought about it Richard
Kimble yeah Dave Kimble Richard Kim
Kimble dang right hang what was that why
was that in my brain see that's amazing
the way the brain works that information
was in there I would have never thought
of that again Richard Kimble came out
until they come up with the next
fugitive that dog can actually get to a
place where there has there is a
footprint and while you as a human can
look at the footprint and no forensic ly
which direction which direction of the
foot was going based on the boot maybe
the foot looks and the way the foot is
oriented a dog actually can analyze
which direction that was going in based
on the way the front of the foot in the
back of the foot smells the footprint
and basically the fact that there is a
difference in time of when the the front
and the back of the foot were on the
ground and they can actually smell the
freakin difference in time they smell in
vectors and it's and then there's all
this crazy stuff about how like if
you're the this the size of the the room
that you can be in with a dog and
introduce like one molecule of stink of
something the smell of something and the
dog knows that it's there like
absolutely phenomenal and they also have
the ability to decipher it and
categorize it in ways that we never do I
mean it's basically like you know you
talk about when a dog's walking around
and peeing on things and smelling things
just like they're getting their email
they're reading their email you know the
level of complexity that information
that comes to you in an email it's like
a dog walking around smelling so I
there's no doubt in my mind that when we
get to like the restaurant that we pass
as we're getting to our house
I think the sequence of smells begins to
come to Barbara in the same battery and
I think because I what happens is she
gets she all of a sudden she's not like
looking up and like seeing a tree that
she recognizes she's like all of a
sudden we get to this place and she gets
up and she starts looking around and she
hasn't done that the whole time I think
it's the sequence it's like a code of
smells that is coming into her brain and
she's like I'm coming home there it is
smell in that house in this house and
exactly it's like hmm
dogs are amazing so local it's a
localized marker now you show me a cat
that can do that that'll change my
worldview they're afraid of cucumbers
yeah cats can't even take cucumbers now
man
your whole speeches really got me
thinking about dog I feel like
tremendously guilty Jade sleeps under
the covers and I fart oh she probably
likes it they like trash they like the
smell the trash what are you thinking
I'm saying that when you fart Jade is
like my owner has just given me a gift
from himself in a way that only he can
know PI she knows exactly who you are
she knows she probably knows how your
day went and what you had for dinner
based on the farts so how was your day
it's like okay I learned all any no but
I will say that when I do that she
quickly scurries out you kidding man
yours gonna be really intense sometimes
carries out from under the comforter
yeah she gets up next to my head after
that she's like I've never smelled that
smell come from this guy I feel horrible
about it is that a great place to end
this podcast probably not but we should
anyway we should end it yeah we should
but hey listen you gotta gear up I got I
got to get that RV start putting stuff
in it I gotta start packing yeah thank
you for
your questions thank you for asking us
anything we tried to answer as many as
we could we didn't get through as many
as we wanted to but you know what we're
gonna do this again let us know how your
high what are you how you processing
your biscuits right now what are you
thinking about your biscuits you know
let us know in the different social
medias with hashtag your biscuits let
your voice be heard yeah will speak at
you next week
[Music]